[Music]
So this is a buddo
and just to keep it simple is you're use
you're using martial arts training as a
technology of self.
Um the technology of self that we're
doing is silk road orient uh derived and
so it's a mysticism.
There are other forms of mysticism where
you do not do martial arts at all
and there are other forms of mysticism
where you do not move at all.
So this begs the question
why do buudo
Um,
if you look within our practice,
it has
drills or exercises
that are not marshall
and that do not move at all.
And this is why I say for these reasons
that there are traditions that don't do
martial arts. There are traditions that
don't do movements and within within our
overall Buddha there are those actual
exercises and drills where you don't
move and you definitely aren't doing
martial stuff.
What what you have to understand is you
can do this technology of self
without having to be marshall without
doing the marshall.
And I've said that many times. So
drill number one is a stillness silence
drill. That's your key practice.
Um servitude.
I'm not fighting people. I'm serving
people
is the key on selfing practice.
So again, it begs the question, why the
marshall?
And the reason you do the marshall
is because the marshall is a
confirmation
exercise, a confirmation field.
I don't think anybody alive today
should be surprised
that while there are
mysticisms
that use silence and stillness and that
not do not have a marshall component.
There's a lot of [\h__\h] liars in those
traditions.
There's a lot of people that on the
outside
are saying and proclaiming one thing,
but on the inside are every bit as
demonpossessed as someone not
proclaiming their mysticism.
So, your Marshall
environment
is one wherein
we're going to put you to the test.
If if you're not sure what that means,
there's a
a line
uh that the Greek author who is
recording
the Spartan battle at Thermopoly
and they're facing the special forces of
the Persian Empire which went by the
name the immortals.
And when the
king of the Spartans was told, you're g
you're going to face the immortals
tomorrow. Get ready to lose. And he
says, we're going to put their [\h__\h]
name to the test. Okay, that that's
that's the idea. You're going to claim
this immortality. Oh, we'll [\h__\h] see.
Okay,
same thing here. You're going to claim
this
mature spirit
that does not get reacted, triggered
into a selfing state.
You're going to claim an agency in
unselfing.
Then let's put you in the environment
most likely to trigger the selfing.
Okay? the fear and the will to power and
the dichotomization of the world and
that's human behum violence and the
cushion while it is perfectly viable the
zafu
and while it can do its stuff it cannot
tell you whether you're doing it or not
which is why you have what in essence
are impotent
religions to this Okay,
you guys may have noticed this. Like,
you know, you could release on the ma,
right? You you're releasing the back
pressure on the ma and we go to a little
bit of violence and like, [\h__\h] that.
That goes all out the window.
Or you might have noticed in your
servitude practice
that you can say yes up to a point
which means it's just kind of coinciding
with
convenience the self hedenism
will power fear all that kind of stuff.
as opposed to
you're going to say yes every single
time
there and then
it's not going to be back burner to
later.
Good. You got that. You're like you
start with yes and then you realize oh
[\h__\h] okay I'm going to do that later.
I'm gonna get to that later. Do you see
that's that's not the practice.
But you can kind of get away with it, so
to speak.
You you you can think in your mind that
you're doing servitude.
But now you got a good reason. And
that's the ego tripartite mind. You got
a good reason now why I can't say yes
now, but I'll say yes in a little bit.
Do you see?
Well, there's no such window of
self-d delusion in the combative
engagement. It's over. It's over by the
time
your ego tripartite mind manipulates the
situation where you come out favorable.
Okay. You either released and unself or
you didn't.
So that that's why we do what we do. Why
there is a buddo?
Why there is a marshall aspect and also
why your marshall aspect itself
cannot be based in delusion which means
why it must be functional practical real
and this is the real spiritual problem
with the choreographed ukare
I don't have a confirmation field in
there that's not going to tell me
anything and when I say that modern
ukami is a icipation of the ego
tripartite mind.
That's exactly what I mean. So modern
modern UKI
is just will to power dichotomy
uh delusion lying. Do you see? And so it
has no spiritual value.
Does this make sense?
So what I want to do here is
just briefly show you
um things that are should have been
obvious to anybody who's trying to
operate at this level of confirmation
but isn't because modern iikido has
assured it and replaced it with selfing
practices.
Okay. uh and one of those is a tami.
The idea is that if my technique stalls
then I do a tami and then I'm
kickstarted again.
And within that idea
there is what I'm just for now calling a
kind of
substitutability
between ai and nagwasa. Okay.
And what I learned in that history that
I gave you is they they're not in the
same place. Okay?
So
those people in the in my past street
sparring classes, I didn't put this in
there, but they weren't all Kempo.
What they all were were fighters.
So my dojo at that time had open
training on those days. Tuesdays and
Thursdays was street sparring and the
door and everyone in this area all the
way to Ventura and up to slow county
people would come from all over who just
wanted to fight and we didn't have um
a style specific street sparring in
other words. Okay. So people were all
different things and no thing. There
were people there was one guy he was
very good. Um he kicked the [\h__\h] out of
me for forever. Um
sorry I can't remember his name. I
should remember his name but he is so
ingrained in me. Um
and really he didn't ever practice a
martial art. He just fought people.
And if I were to describe what he would
do, and maybe if he described what he
would do, it was dirty boxing. It's like
just cheap in boxing is all he was. Um,
so here's somebody, no rank. Um, he
didn't wear ghee. We didn't care. Um, no
rank, no no school affiliation, nothing.
Bruce.
Bruce. Okay. Uh, and Bruce would just
come in and beat the [\h__\h] out of all of
us, uh, for a long time till you learn
uh, this more universal system style
that you had to develop to fight
everybody from different specializing
schools. Okay. Um, and he was older than
us, too. So, I was in my 20s and Bruce
was in his 40s. And uh you know back
then when I was in my 20s, when you were
in your 40s, you were a [\h__\h] old
fart. And uh Bruce would kick the [\h__\h]
out of us. And then he always had like
these two young uh blonde women that
were in their 20s come meet him because
he was going to go play tennis the rest
of the night with these totally smoking
hot women. Okay. So, I don't know what
what Bruce did, but he also would coach
us like get us out of the style, okay?
Get us out of style and just be in the
moment fighting. This basically that's a
confirmation field. Do do you see? Uh
because in the style and in the tendency
towards the style is the self and is the
self- reification.
Uh this is how you have shuhari
is the earliest one. shoe is really just
self
self form self and then then you have
the dichotomy with non-formed you see
that when when you're in a shoe state of
mind you're just you're in the everyday
state of mind the ego tripartite mind
okay and Bruce would just
beat the [\h__\h] out of you every time you
did it every time you did it. Okay, so
you had to learn how not to do it um
right there and then. And there was no
I'm doing it. You there was no I doing
it because you got the [\h__\h] beat out of
you and you're dead on the mat and the
40-year-old is walking out happy as can
be to go play tennis or whatever he was
going to do. Okay.
Um,
and in that environment of all these
different people trying to get past
style, which is not was not a new idea
to martial arts even then, everyone knew
about Bruce Lee and his protest against
style. Um,
people knew that. That's why my
instructor then had this open sparring.
You fight everybody. Uh, and that's why
everyone in there was borrowing and
stealing from each other uh, in the goal
to try to not get your ass kicked for an
hour and a half or two hours. Okay.
Um,
as a confirmation field, you you can
learn what is what is delusion, what is
not delusion.
As the cushion has no confirmation field
to it, you don't learn that. You get to
just say that. And as modern iikido has
no confirmation field to it, again, they
just say it. They don't confirm whether
it's true or not. So then they come up
with ego tripartite mind derived ideas
such as striking and throwing are
substitutable. They don't understand.
They're not substitutable. Okay.
If you remember in that environment and
in that history, what happened was is I
learned how to dominate mid-range
striking. But look, looking at it now is
that's all that happened. There was a
higher propensity towards mid-range
striking.
Um, not really because of style per se,
but just for the nature of the
environment. So, for example, there was
no weapons,
right? and there's no multiple
attackers. Well, then the safest thing
to do is stay in mid-range and dominate
mid-range until you gain initiative and
then you would go in for your takedowns
and your chokes and and whatever. Uh,
that wasn't Bruce's style, though. He
would just beat the [\h__\h] out of you for
mid-range striking, okay? He could do
that.
If we had put multiple people in there
and we put weapons, we wouldn't have
people inclined towards staying or
centering their
art around mid-range striking. Okay.
But when I started dominating the
mid-range striking with Kempo,
which gives you way more angles of
attack and way more targets
uh than dirty boxing would,
people started trying to get around
that. And the way they got around it was
just bum rush through mid-range
striking.
And
the reason that worked is because I
couldn't strike them while they're
bumrushing me.
And that tells you that you can't strike
where you could throw. It just doesn't
happen. Okay? If you could strike, they
wouldn't be bumrushing you. Okay?
Um and so they're not interchangeable.
Why Iikido keeps positing that idea is
for the following reasons. One, they
don't understand that Kihon Waza is not
a self-defense technique. It is it is a
a form technology. And what I mean by
that is
these are mimmonic devices that allow
information to be passed through
history.
They're not necessarily a plug a
plugandplay technology.
So if you have a form for example a so a
solo form
um
you have all this hidden information in
the solo form that as you get more
understanding of the form you start
realizing
um that for example that's not an inward
block and a reverse punch. So the short
form one in or short or long form one in
kempo was step back inward block and uh
reverse punch and you did it at all the
cardinal directions very much like hapo
giddy. Okay make understand
>> okay and so you as a beginner
>> you that you think that you had an
inward block. So he did a straight
punch, right? It would be right here.
And you would go here. Boom. Boom. Do do
you get the idea? And so you you think
you that's what the form is. Um and then
eventually you'd go to Mr. Parker. Like
I trained with Mr. Parker and then he
would have the master key to unlock this
mimmonic device that took information
and passed it through history. And you
you realize boom this is this was a
block a break on there then then
followed by a a rib shot. Do you see
that where no one saw that first cuz
everyone went here
right and then he would do the next time
that's actually a neck crank in there
and this on and they start putting it in
everywhere. Okay.
Um,
and then the fool thinks, "Oh, it's a
block or it's a break." Not realizing it
could be pretty much whatever you need
it to be. Um,
because it's just working on rotation
and counter rotation. It's working on
forward and reverse motion and how they
complement each other. It's it's working
on these concepts. Do you see? Um, so if
you have a form and you're doing like uh
a technique uh like this, do you see?
And then you go here. It doesn't
necessarily mean that that's your line,
that's your story, that's your
narrative. When someone grabs you, you
step out and you punch him and then you
go here. It's just information like bop.
That could be the damn end of the
technique. Now the mimmonic device is
going to go okay when you're in this
situation. You have this much lean here
and he's here. That's when you can come
in and do it. It's not necessarily the
case that the strike meant to go with
the grappling. Do you get? It's just
here's more information that we can pass
down through space. Okay? And people
don't understand that about forms
training anymore. They don't understand
that pri prior civilizations
did not have uh databases and video
libraries and things like that and a lot
of it wasn't even written down. Uh you
just memorize this and then the
instructor pulls out the system for you
as you're practicing. Okay.
So,
I don't even know if O sensei understood
that to tell you the truth because for
example, I'm telling you the truth. You
can't do the strike where you would do
the throw. It's one or the one or the
other. Okay. Um, and he I don't know how
everyone that worked after him
got the delusion
without him not correcting them. Do Do
you get So, I don't did why didn't he
correct them? Maybe he didn't know.
Maybe by his time he's still doing
forms. But if you look at when he's
doing live training, he's not throwing
the ATM in there. He's just going on
with the throw. And no one goes
um no one says, "Where the [\h__\h] are the
strikes?
Why aren't you doing the strikes?" Okay.
So
to show how they're not
substitutable
and that they're one or the other even
if a form looks like it has it in there.
Uh we're going to do an exercise from uh
Rav's video. Okay. So we're doing the
oshidto. All right. And we have this
strike right here. Okay.
Uh,
he's coming around, right? Boom.
What do you What's it doing?
What's it do? It's stopping his motion.
Okay. And I need that centrifugal energy
to uh
get my I adhesion and my spiral rotation
of the fight. Do you understand? So if
if we come around here and I hit here
and he stops, well now you're in
mid-range striking. Do you see? So
here's where
you would go on from there. That's what
you would do. The fight stopped. It's
now open again to mid-range striking.
Okay.
Um
but let's say he's coming around. Boom.
and come around for the hand.
>> Okay, he's coming around. Boom. And
where'd he go on that little strike? He
He went boom. Do you see that?
>> And so his that energy is now counter to
this energy. Do you see that? So um
so as he's coming around
and um
take some things to heart now I'm not
throwing it my hardest or my insides
will blow out but it sent him that way
it it's going to be crazy Now, as we'll
come back, you know, right here, just
right there. It's going to be crazy to
go like this. Do you see that? That's a
yongyang clash there that you wouldn't
do that. Okay. Um, couple things. Why
does it look like it works?
One, we don't understand the need for
centrial centrifugal energy in adhesion
and cook in ike and ki. We don't we
don't even know about it. We're just
going to do linking. Okay. Uh two, we
actually can't throw the strike to
displace that guy. Okay. Um
and then three, we don't throw the
strike. So the guy's just there,
right? You're just here.
>> There's no displacement. Do do you see
that?
>> But displacement. Boom. And he's not
going the other way. Okay. So, throwing
it throwing it a little harder that
time. And you can see the effect of the
strike if it was an actual real strike
takes him out of the technique. Do do
you guys see that? Um, now if he uh if
you keep going really hard
>> for the other hand, Let me put it to you
as engineers. What do you think you're
going to see?
>> Strike.
>> The strike is going to be smothered. So,
the way to protect yourself on this
strike, just do the actual attack. Okay.
He started pushing on that side right
away. Okay. Um, hence they're not
interchangeable. If you were able to get
the strike, you're going to knock him
out of the technique and you should just
go on with the other stuff. Okay, make
sense? Okay, so let's have you guys play
with
uh try to throw it. You're going to see
that's a lot of grounding. Okay. Um
because we actually don't do we don't
strike that way because it's still a
yongyang strike. Okay. That's a sucky
target also because the target
on terms of the weapon
is we'll just look at it here
is
up here on the chest area and he's on
the fleshy part of my arm. Okay,
>> that that is why it displays so much. If
you could ground if you could ground
it's going to move move him. Okay. um
elbows to the front here. Your only
target is the is the solar plex is here
with the spear. Do you see that? So if I
I'll just do it a little light. Okay,
that's a soft target. That'll that'll
work. Okay, but this this one is very
much just like a shove because it got so
smothered by the target. And for that
reason, if you just attack, you'll
smother the strike. Okay. In other
words, if he if he's he's trying to
smother uh the You're fine. If he's
trying to smother that one. Got him. You
see?
So, that's the spear of my elbow on his
solar plexus. It It worked. Okay. Do you
got it? Um, so for those who don't know
what happened on on the first one, he
came head that way because you see it
closed it. That would be a miss. So on
the second rep, I knocked him on that
side and then boom, and then it goes
into the solar plex. Okay. Uh, but while
I got that opening,
you would capitalize upon it with
striking. You you wouldn't go Let's do
it slow. So I'm here and I hit that.
You're not going to go here.
Okay. You're just gonna beat the [\h__\h]
out of him. Okay. All right. So, play
with this. All right. All right. Before
we start training, uh
him coming around and smothering the
strike is exactly what those fighters
learn. Just press through mid-range
striking and they start to smother
stuff. Okay. So, what
like you're not going to like the strut.
You're I think what we're going to see
is you're going to get displaced because
you can't ground just like every modern
Iikido. That's that's not a that's not
an easy one to do to tell you the truth.
Um,
but you're still not going to like the
strike probably. So the the more you
hate the strike, just come in faster, do
the bum rushing, and you'll smother the
strike every single time. Okay? So,
first like take a take a few and we're
probably going to see the naga move.
Okay? But after a while, maybe as soon
as you hate it or they're never going to
get it, then start smothering the strike
by bum rushing through mid-range
striking. Okay. All right. Try it.
You gota you got to try to do it. You
got to try to do it.
Okay. So, here on Balchain, we don't
have enough force. There's zero effect
on it. Do do you see that? So, let's go
again. You're going to try to get her.
You try to get her. Get her, B. No,
you're not. Okay. And and this was this
would be what would happen to most um
and when I say most I mean like 99.9%
of modern Iikido is they're not they
don't have the force they don't have the
force output to actually do what we
think
you're going to do. And what we think is
you're going to be so incapacitated
that now I can manipulate you in that
moment of incapacitation. Do do you guys
understand that? That's that's what we
think is going to happen when modern
iikido explains a tami. Um in in law
enforcement we have the uh taser
and we teach to arrest under the
neuromuscular incapacitation
because the guy's body like right and
when his body's like that you you kind
of move it around. Okay. Um, but there's
no there's no incapacitation
on the sati on 99.9% of people is my
first point there. And on my second
point, if you could do it, it would just
move him out of the technique, not open
the technique. Okay. All right. So,
let's try it. So, that's one thing we
saw is that we just don't have the
capacity to actually infringe upon my
opponent. Okay. Go. Keep going.
And then she So you had the capacity and
it just moved her out of the technique.
Okay. And so you go, "Oh, let's uh
let's do the math though." Okay. Let's
do the physics. It's just physics. Um
cuz that's what's being confirmed. Uh
why did it knock her out of the
technique?
>> I have a lot more mass.
>> Yeah, he's a lot more mass than her. So
we up the mass
and we'll see what happens.
And he got displaced. Okay. So again,
99.9 and really that's just mathematical
probability. You know, it's got to be
someone [\h__\h] out. I don't know who
they are. Okay. I I've never seen them.
Okay. Uh I've seen them in even in
Kempo. There was only one or two people
aside from me whose hands actually
displaced mass. Okay. Everyone else did
what Mr. Pit called pitterpatter,
which means you you're just touching
people. You're not really damaging
people. Okay. Uh so really the only ones
I saw that were not doing pitterpatter
was Ed Parker, Mr. pick and me and that
was it. Everyone else was pretty
impressive
um in the way that modern nagget are
impressive. Uh so you you can start to
tell like nah that's not that's not
going to do what it needs to do and go
you go ahead and hit them and they did
not drop or they did not move. Okay. It
just looked like it might do it. Okay.
All right. So keep going and we're
self-discovery here.
[Music]
And you're going to start to feel how
yeah, they're just it's a it's a poor
weapon selection, poor target selection.
It's fleshy on a big broad target and
it's just going to move them out or me
get smothered. Okay. All right. Go to
the bum rushing part now where you just
attack very aggressively for the second
hand. Okay.
And just smother the elbow.
Good. Good.
Good.
Throw it. Throw it your hardest and
they're going to smother it. Good.
Good. Yes.
and switch partners and do more
discovery learning and there's a kind of
takes a kind of some balls right like
because you're like that strike is there
and again the people I were fighting
with they were on no shortage of balls
okay so they they just were like I'm run
if I run past that it's kind of
counterintuitive because you you want to
be cautious do you see but no this is
violence of action we're going in and
we're smothering that thing and your
safety is on the other side of that fear
Okay. All right. Continue.
>> Yes.
Don't Don't even worry whether you check
it or not. Just come around enough. It's
going to be smothered.
Yes, that's an exact Energy
went that way. Okay. He He did throw it,
but Energ is still going that way. The
strike got smothered. Okay.
>> All right. Uh
comments, questions?
You can stay standing.
>> Yeah. Low. is a very low quality target.
Okay. Uh but moderro thinks anytime I
anytime I I do any of these strike pose,
you're going to get NMI. You're you're
not going to get NMI. It's the exact
opposite. Okay. Got it. Okay. So, uh
>> don't worry about me. Okay. He's going
to come around and he's going to smother
that strike.
>> Okay.
and
you'll see how much easier that stupid
technique is. Okay, understand?
>> Okay, so but he has to come around and
not get hit.
>> And you now just keep it going. Now
you're in Naga. Okay, so try that one.
Come around like you're not get hit or
we will start hitting you. Okay,
>> cuz here's the selfieing. So, go back to
selfieing. In your fear now of the fall,
you start protecting against the fall.
Well, that's not bum rushing now. And
now you're open to the striking. Do you
see? And then we beat the [\h__\h] out of
you in striking. And now you go back to
bum rushing. Do you get that? Well,
that's your dichomous world view. Okay.
So, grab your balls and freaking come in
and rush. You're you're going to fall.
Okay? There's no way around it. You're
going to fall. Okay? Try it.
>> So that
feel that did you see that? That was
your hesitation there, Virginia. Okay.
This is what you didn't see in you don't
see in Ronin and Tristan because they
don't want to get hit. Do you see that?
So, they're not going to protect
themselves from going out of the frying
pan into the fire kind of thing. Okay?
So, you just go for it.
Smother, smother, smother, smother.
Good. Don't pull. You got to still do
iikido. So, you got to lower them in
their energy.
Yeah. Good. Let's switch sides. Chris,
you come to this side because he's got
you're you're panicking now, Sean, and
you're pulling your your hand out of her
grip.
>> Okay, go for it.
Good. Good. And it's easy. It's easy
peasy, right? Right, Chris? Okay, go
again. We'll watch Chris again. Don't
pull, Virginia. Just stay with his grip.
Good. That's it.
Okay, got G got the idea. Switch rolls.
Switch rolls.
>> Good. Yep. You don't you don't need any
fancy stances. Okay.
You're pulling. You're pulling.
>> He's going to push your hand down.
There you go. Yep. Try it again. Same
side. Just relax.
Good. Yep. That's it. Okay. All right.
Questions, comments, observations?
Yep.
I guess
just letting that energy
go where that energy wants to go.
>> Yeah.
>> And letting
the I guess the falling architecture
>> like if if I tried to take it that way
you probably run that way.
>> Yeah.
>> But if I let him push it
to where there's a point of no return
for him.
>> Yeah. He's gonna he's going to go it and
it's just natural. Okay. So we have we
have a senpai coohigh ranking here and
we rank that according to skill. Okay.
And we we know from training with each
other that out of this group he's the
highest at the internals. You guys kind
of trade places back and forth. You're
still trying to do things external.
Okay. And if we look at this allowance
like allow that to happen, he has an
easier time allowing it to happen and
it's just stupid effortless at that
point. Okay? And then we had to talk you
into doing it and then you guys are
pulling on their hands and trying to
make something happen. And now now the
technique is as bad as trying to smother
it. Okay? Why can't you manipulate it
and pull it? Uh because there's too much
force on it. trajectory in the same way
that there's too much force for that
strike to be viable. It gets smothered.
Okay? So, the same thing there's too
much force for you to try to change that
direction too radically. You're going to
lose connection on the grip and not
allow their attack to actually take
their balance as you are trying to take
their balance. Okay? There's just too
much force on it. Um, so this is why you
have to match the yong value, right? So
it's I call it you could say match the
yin. It doesn't matter. You're matching
the energetic value. I call it yong
because they're the coming in with yong
energy. So you have to match the yong
value which means I'm not pulling it but
if I go too weak it'll it'll collapse my
radius in this case my arm. Okay. Uh so
you guys are over yonging and the force
is too great for that. Okay. You can't
overy yong this force. You don't you
don't want to just let it be. Okay.
Uh any anything Andrew?
>> Yeah.
>> Yep. Okay. And then um
Yeah. because you it'll get caught on
your head because you're trying to make
it do something else or you come out of
the grip. You can't continue the the
kazushi angle long enough for the
topsyturvy effect. Okay, all that kind
of stuff happens. All right. Um, now go
back to the selfing aspect. It takes a
lot of calming down. It takes a lot of I
don't feel attacked.
If you have a selfieing, you're going to
feel attacked. Okay? If you don't have a
selfie, you don't feel attacked and you
can just follow that path. If you don't
feel attacked, you won't try to
manipulate the yong energy. Okay. All
right.
>> Yeah.
>> One more thing.
>> And that's what I'm talking. That's
that. So that's I I chalk that up as
fear. Not remember fear is not just
ghosts. I'm afraid of ghosts. But it's
the self that's coming in and now you
can't accept reality as it is. So you're
going to try to manipulate it. That's
the will to power. Do you see? But
that's not our art. That is the the
other side of nature. Okay. The demonic
side. Um, in dowist terms, it's wooue.
Uh, don't do anything. They do
something. Okay. You're trying to do
something. Not wooi. Okay. Um, and then
we see this. You're over yang in what is
already too high a yong and you can't do
it. Okay. Um, you want a second chance
at just letting just letting it go.
Okay. go back to your releasing drills
and don't get triggered by how much
force on the grab or anything
and they're just going to go. Okay?
Don't you don't have to accelerate them.
They're coming in plenty hard and fast.
So when you get don't try to cut down,
just get it over your head and slowly
lowering it with them as as their energy
is being vectorred towards the ground.
Okay. All right. Try it again.
>> Calm down. Release the self.
>> That would be under under y.
Good. Yep. Good.
All right. Switch rolls. We'll give give
you got you got to release. Gotta
release noises.
Better. Yep. Yep. You're fine.
There you go.
Release. Accept.
You have a kind of acceleration of him
behind your head. Okay.
There you go. Yep. Exactly.
Yep. You're fine. At the end, you you
want you have a you have a a a vector
that you want him to throw. We don't
have a vector. He he he's going to fall
anywhere on the clock principle that I
keeping his balance breaking. Don't go.
He should fall by now because that's
where you're yawn in it. Okay. Try it
again.
>> Just keep lowering his energy outside
his base of support.
Yep. Very good. See, easy peasy. You're
going to keep going. You're going to
calm down more and relax more. Yep. Very
good.
Yep. Good. Okay.
Got it. Okay. So, that's the So, you
could be on the cushion, do you see? And
you could talk about unselfing the whole
[\h__\h] time and they all [\h__\h] do.
Okay. I'm sorry. They just do. They're
all the whole world is sick. Okay. Um
and here though, we put you to the test
and then you could do it. But now what
you need to do is have a practice where
it never gets triggered and you don't
need the teacher's
aid to get to an unselfing state. Okay?
Do do you understand that? Um because
that's not a true practice. That's
that's my practice,
not your practice. Okay, got it. Okay.
Okay. The next mistake or delusion,
misnomer in modern IKEA is pain.
Um, pain is relative,
but like every time you put your hand up
there, the modern Iikidoka treats it as
a universal generator of NMI, okay,
neuromuscular incapacitation.
And we know it's not true. It's
relative. It's relative to your skill,
to weapon selection, target selection.
It's not it. Okay? It only looks
universal because no one in Iikido
actually throws the strike. They just go
ahead and assume the effect. Okay?
Um pain is likewise relative. So first
to go back to unselfing pain is a
selfing experience.
Pain physical pain uh is not experienced
from the god mind. And this is why in
mystical traditions throughout history,
the body is put under that kind of
stress where you go from discomfort to
self-mutilation.
Is there testing for this ability for
pain to go away? Okay. Um, some of you
have been close enough and long enough
with me that you know that's exactly
what I do all the time. Um, trying to
deal. So for example, I've mentioned
that night with the with the pain like I
was in my narrative what you were could
have heard was I'll I can address this
pain but I got concerned with that
cardiac event and really the only thing
that drove me to the cardiac concern was
uh Mary would be very upset with me if I
die. Okay? Uh because she would be alone
with the kids. Do you get that? So, um,
it's not the pain that got me to the
hospital and stuff. It it's the
servitude practice that made me go to
where I normally don't go. Okay. Um, and
and she knows that about me. She can't
stand that about me because because
she's afraid.
She's afraid of pain. Okay. And we
probably are afraid of pain, too.
Um
there was one point at the at the
hospital where you know I was hooked up
to every single monitor
and um I get wheeled into pre-surgery
and the uh anesthesiologist sees all
those stickers on me and you know from
the from the probes and stuff they're
all over me and u they uh there's like a
lot on my hair here, right? And uh she's
all, "Oh, oh, they I wish they would
have took those off." And I'm all like,
"Just pull it off." And she's like,
"Well, I don't want to hurt." And even
Mary goes, "He doesn't feel pain." And
so the nurse is like, "Okay." She's
okay. Um
but if you release the self and you
accept what's happening, your your body
does not feel the pain. Okay.
It's no different with emotional pain,
your emotional pain. You're you always
have a physical response to it like
upset stomach, you know, I can't
breathe, uh chest palpitations, all this
kind. If you release, you don't feel
those things. They go right away. There
are things of the ego tripartite mind.
Okay. So pain is very relative. at the
top we have you're going to have
opponents who could release from that
and you won't have the NMI effect
because you're hurting them and that
could go anywhere from they'll let you
break whatever you think you're going to
break or the extra time in which you
didn't generate NMI they are out in the
stupidest of ways okay which is why
iikido does have joint locks but we are
not trying to induce pain from the joint
lock. We are controlling the center. You
understand that? So, go back to the Nico
videos. And I'm moving your body through
space. Okay? Um, if you can't release,
you're going to feel the joint. Okay? Go
back now to me as uk. You can't hurt me
with that technique. There's no pain in
that technique. Okay? It's not that
you're not cranking on it. It's just
it's not going to do what you think it's
going to do. Okay. So, here we have uh
the guy comes around and we have this.
You see, and then you have that that
that pain. Okay. Got got the idea.
Um and again, he stopped.
So, you stopped him. So, now you
generate the energetic problem that's
not there. Okay.
And um then he moves
because he has a owie. Do do you
understand that? Okay. So I'll show you
what I mean. He comes around and you
stop the energy and then he goesh and he
moves he moves out of the way. Okay. So
uh he he I'm sorry. We'll trade rules
and we're just going to show you this.
You got to be calm. Okay. You're going
to come in. He's gonna get it. Okay.
He's gonna crank it.
That's what he's doing. Okay. So, we'll
start over.
Come in.
Boom.
And that's all we're going to do.
Okay. So, I don't know if the camera got
it. We'll figure it out. Okay. Coming
around.
Okay. So, here he is right here because
I have my balance and I stopped. Then I
have my striking ability and all I'm
going to do is boom, hit through the
grip. That's all you're going to do.
That's all you're going to do. Okay. So,
try that one.
>> Go.
You got to hit it like you mean it. You
got to ground. Yeah. Not your own hand.
Turn. Turn your hips and everything.
You're avoiding the pain in your hand.
>> Yep.
Yep.
You got to stop. He's going to stop you.
>> That way you have your mid-range
striking. Hit hit his forearm, not the
lock.
>> Stop. Yeah. Turn. Don't grab it. Just
hit it hard. That's it. You You brought
your rear foot up. See, you lost power.
Boom. Hit.
Good.
Okay. Again, you need to be able to
ground. Okay. Uh, we're doing Nikio.
Okay. And he goes and you're likeh,
okay, got the idea. And again, what I'm
showing you is just the simplest way
that once you stop the fight, it goes
back into all my strikes are available
now. Okay. What modern Iikido says is
they're going to go ow. And it doesn't
matter that they're in balance.
They're gonna be
mesmerized by the pain. Okay. So, it it
doesn't matter. Okay. So, here here we
are. You see there's no balance
breaking.
Go until here. Okay. Got it. So, from
here
there's my window. Okay. Got it.
>> So, let's say you get in that lock. Get
it? Yep. Sure. And he goes, you going to
do it? We'll do it again towards the
camera. Maybe if you're there. Okay.
Boom. He gets in there. Yep. That's it.
It's all I'm doing. Look at his grips.
Do you see his grips? Stay where you
are.
>> And let's just open it up a little. Stay
where you are. I'm going to come back
out here. Okay, here's the opening on
the thumb. Here's the opening on the
thumb. Okay, he's going in and I just
come out that opening. Okay, and it's
very quick. He goes, "Go, go. Turn it.
You got to turn it, dude. You got to do
Nikio. However you want to do Nikio."
Cool. And I'm out. And it's all
And it's all because I can move. Okay,
try it. Go.
Let him turn it. Let him get there. Be
calm.
Yes.
Okay.
>> All right. So that is why if we were
doing coming around uh we don't go back
this way.
[Music]
>> You you have to keep his energy going
around.
You see? And so the the pain's there
like you tried to reverse but it also
with the pain
is that I'm continuing him moving. Do
you see? And so I'm not stopping the
energy because he's not going to be in
NMI where for that split second I could
do whatever I want to him. Okay? You
have to keep the energy moving. Okay?
So, all I'm doing is there's that force
and I just keep it going around. It's
the same technique on this one. He's
here and you just brought it around to
here.
You're just going to trade hands. That
is all you're going to do.
Okay. Try it.
Yep.
You got to be in the right place at the
right time. Still,
you're at the wrong place.
You're a little late.
Yep.
>> Trade partners.
>> Yep.
Yep.
Follow that main energy. It's the same
exact idea. You got to follow the yang.
better. So, do the releasing practice.
>> You still I still have the lock in air
quotes there. I still have the lock.
Okay. What you two are doing is you
don't have the lock. So, go slow and
I'll show you what I mean. Okay. You're
here and you're kind of just pulling it.
>> Do you see that? And you're you're
pulling down like that.
This energy
is doing this.
It's going here, which is the lock. Do
you understand?
>> So, you can't go here and just pull
straight down. Eventually, you're going
to just be pulling against the shoulder.
The shoulder wants to go out.
>> You still have a turn that that people
think is there. I still have the turn.
Okay. Such such that
if he
tried to pick up his try to pick up his
shoulder, he'll feel that
resistance on it. You see, it's just
when he tries to pick up the shoulder,
I'm keep his center moving. Okay.
>> But it's there. Okay. Try it again.
>> Yeah.
>> That would be the 90.
>> Yes. Yeah. That's if you It's the same
thing when we do eio. You got to do all
the angles to get around. This is giving
you all the angles. Okay. Go.
[Music]
Keep turning it. Keep turning it. You
see how his hand is the other way?
>> Look, your thumb has to be on the
bottom. Your pinky on top.
>> Keep turning it. Keep turning your thumb
down. Your pinky on top.
Turn, turn, turn, turn, turn.
>> Yep.
Okay.
>> But notice what we did is they kept
moving. If they didn't move, all their
strikes would be available. and his
count counters as stupid and just
overpowering my lock would be uh
available to them. Okay. What's not
available to to the realistic person is
the NMI. They're they're not they don't
go in NMI like iikido thinks. Okay. Um
that same problem is in law enforcement.
They do a lot of pain compliance
techniques. So you can see a lot of
videos of people who are high uh people
who are mentally ill. they can't make a
rational decision and compliance is a
rational decision. Do you see that? Um
and then people who are just
hyperaggressive
um they don't comply. They don't go into
that NMI effect. They keep on fighting.
Okay.
Okay. The last one I want to deal with
is
um the lead follow stuff.
Um in our art
they I don't lead them anywhere
and they don't follow me anywhere. They
are being made to move from A to B.
This begins first with rule number one
of Uki. Okay. So rule number one is you
have to do the prescribed attack meaning
they are first prescribed to move from A
to B. Do do you understand that? So what
to demonstrate this if I am UK and I'm
doing
I by prescription have to start on the
outside here
and end over here. Okay. It's just the
rules.
Um, anybody who stopped along the way
did not do rule number one. Okay, got
everyone understand that? Okay.
What after what happens to here?
UK does not move themselves
anymore. They now get moved. And the
beginning of me moving them happens
somewhere in the prescription. Okay, got
that? So what what you have here is a
microcosm of this technology of self.
We coming to the world in the ego
tripartite mind default setting. We are
a dichotomy.
He is staying still. I am moving. I
initiate, he waits. Do you see the
dichotomy? I am UK. He is nag.
What we are doing is concentrically
taking the dichomous world view and
going to the communion world view. Okay.
So in the time that I am doing the
fulfillment of my dichotomy, we must
stop being him versus me and he must now
commune with me. Okay? So I'll show you
what I mean.
You you got to go really slow so you
could feel it. Okay? As he's coming in,
that's him as I yield. Do you see that?
Okay. But and now you're starting to
feel just just stay there and you'll see
what I mean. Okay. So, I can feel uh the
yongyang matching here. And you'll see
if I if I change it. Do you feel that?
>> Okay. Somewhere in there somewhere I I
release the self and then the communion
starts to happen. Okay.
I don't fight that value, but I'm
controlling it. So, at this point, you
you can do whatever you want to his
center. Understood?
>> But the technique per prescription,
I'm going to work with the guy that's
coming from the back. Okay?
We've now not dichomous at at contact.
Here we go. And now I am or and he,
however you want to say it, we're moving
together, which he's not really
controlling the technique anymore.
>> Okay. Got Got it.
Um,
let's let's talk about it for a second
and maybe you could feel it. But what I
was trying to show is if I can go
anywhere from anything and move his
center, it's clear that it's not that
we're not two things at that point.
Okay. Um so I could project I could have
projected out. I could have brought him
in front of me and I can control the
rate at which he's going around me. Two
have become one. Okay. Got the communion
has happened. I has happened. Okay. Um,
but I don't know how visible it is or
how how sensitive you are to feel it,
but to me that's logical. What What do
you got? What' you see? What' you feel?
What' you see?
Yeah. Not him. Okay. I've just communed
with his prescription. It's what you're
doing. Okay. And the fact that I could
change the prescription is the is
evidentiary that we are in a communion
state right now. Okay.
Um,
so it's not even by the time he gets
there, it's not the case that he got
himself there. Do do you understand? He
he's going to go there at that point at
that point cuz I'm not going to let him
go any other place
while prescription wise he is going to
go there too. Too often the nag even
here will take advantage entirely of the
prescription and now you're trying to
find their center over here and that
just doesn't work and but it is
uh cosmologically
incorrect. It's why I always say at
touch you're already gaining this
communion of iik tanden. Okay. if to try
to find it here at the end. That's where
they're going to stop. That's where
you're going to need them to stop.
That's where you start plugandplay this
[\h__\h] about strikes and about pain
compliance and all that kind of stuff.
Okay, Chris
is coming up in class trying to get
Ready, set, go. And trying to
emulate your capacity to already
one, two, three, rep four. That entire
turn keeps
And without that, it seems like there's
no way to even come close to the right
lines, the right
>> there's no way outside of choreography,
which is why they need choreography.
There is no way outside of choreography
because you're always going to be either
too late or too early because
cosmologically you're in a dichomous
state and you got to try to
mathematically figure this out and guess
and that's just not highly likely. Okay.
Yes. Very good, very good insight. Okay.
So, in a way, it's kind of cheating. I
don't have perfect timing because I
don't have a timing problem.
That's the way to solve it. Okay?
There's I don't I'm not I don't have to
be too early or too late. We're we're
together. Okay? There's no past,
present, there's no him, I Okay. All
right. So
when we're doing this technique,
energetics is just energetics. Again,
it's not uh electromagnetism.
And let me be clear when I say NMI,
neuromuscular capacitation. What I mean
is there's no universal technique in
which the opponent becomes my slave and
lets me do everything. That that's not
real. So the chi people that have the
electromagnetism
and they do that in that
lack of ability
they can be totally manipulated by the
nag in ways that real fighters know that
that's not how it works. Okay. So
leading following is another one of
those examples. Okay. Instead, if you
realize that the connection that I'm
going to have here is going to have yin
and yang phases, too. It's not a
universal incapacitation of him where
once I touch him, uh, he's like that and
you you could do whatever. Do do you
understand? There's going to be a
yinface where the connection cannot be
maintained and achieve the same ends.
Um, does that make sense? Okay, it in a
yin-yang world that's a fact. But no, no
one wants to acknowledge that. They just
get incapacitated and you can move
however you want or even not touch them.
Do you see this all crazy stuff? Okay.
So, uh, as we're coming around here and
he's feeling the connection, he's
feeling the connection. Then it's kind
of off here, isn't it, Sean?
>> Do you see that?
uh and there's nothing I can do to to
generate that center connection at that
point. Okay? Uh
meaning when I'm here like this, okay?
And at this point, um
I I'll be I'll be here. I'll be in in
this kind of thing, right? But you know,
it's not in your center.
>> So he can move
any way he freaking wants. Do do you
understand? He can move any way he
freaking wants.
So that's why in the admin as you're
coming around, you have to pick it up
over here.
Do you
do you understand? and he can't stop
because then I won't have the the
centrifugal energy to generate the
adhesion on the outside of his head.
Okay? Does that does that make sense? So
you're you're going to you're going to
go he coming in. He's going to feel he's
going to feel that and he feels this.
Okay? And it's it just comes around.
Okay?
If I grab his sleeve as in Robbie's
video, do you see that? It's just
energy.
There's too much energy leakage on the
sleeve.
Understand?
>> So, if he
pulls my sleeve, it's even higher on the
shoulder where you'd have more control.
Uh, and as he's pulling it, then I can
move all over the place.
>> Got it. I don't have to move where
you're telling me is. You can't make me
move where you're telling me because
there's no there's not going to be a
center to center connection with that
much energy leakage. Okay. Do do you
guys got that? So, uh, when he's coming
around, okay, boom. And I go to the
sleeve. You got a couple things. You got
all that energy leakage. So, watch his
center. Do you see?
Didn't do anything to it. Okay. And then
you always have the shoulder hinge. You
see? Okay. So, with between the energy
leakage of the sleeve and the energy
absorption of the shoulder, I could move
this thing pretty freaking far. in space
and never affect the center as long as
you stay relaxed. Okay,
[Music]
that is just not going to work. Okay, so
when I
go to pull it
in with the way that he's staying still,
he could also move anywhere he wanted in
the capacity to stay still against my
movement. when I go to move it where I
feel tension like there, I can't control
where he's going to step. Do you
understand? So, you're going to uh
you're going to pull me around. So, it
looks like I got taken that way. Do you
understand?
He has that. And again, it's even more
control on the shoulder. Okay. See, he's
going and it looks like I'm going
around,
but he can't stop me from
moving any old way. Do Do you
understand?
>> Whereas when he's coming around, right,
and we're here,
he can't go the other ways. He's only
going to go that way. Okay? So, if
you're
if he pulled
And the UK
did what you saw him do. You did that.
Not not the nag. Do you guys understand
that? And you don't want to do that. So
this is why I do these demonstrations.
Okay. So we're here and we connect and
we let go and we tell him pull out that
way.
Okay, we tell him go forward.
>> We tell him go backwards.
>> Do you understand? So, do you feel the
resistance? Okay, and that was without
motion. When you add the motion, let's
start walking.
>> And now you feel
less ability to change what vector he's
on and how he's moving through it. Okay.
The justification
for this is following.
But following is not true. Following is
that selfing delusion. Okay? You need to
be made to move by that point in the
technique by nag from wherever they
touched you to wherever you go.
There's nothing you have to do as uk.
And so what you should do is
follow rule two.
He neither assists nor resist. Okay? Do
so if if I can't move him there, he
shouldn't go. He shouldn't go. I have to
be able to move him there. Got it?
>> Okay. So again, this is about UK being
brave. So he's going and I'm just
standing.
Okay,
I'm not being an ass, but I'm just
standing. He's got to move. Then now he
could learn
where the technique actually is cuz he
did eventually move me. But you'll never
get to adima from that technique because
he went too down. Okay. All right. So
that's our discovery learning. Just
stand still. Okay. Which is way less.
There's going to be way less energy you
can use when you had the forward
progress of the prescribed attack. When
you have the forward progress where
you're coming in to smother that strike,
there's no way that one wouldn't work.
Okay? But to get in the ballpark, just
stand still. Stay connected. Don't go
soupy. Stay connected. And he's got to
move your mass. Okay?
What he felt was, "Oh, I'm just yong
yonging." So, he's trying to find the
right angle. Well, that is closer to the
art than you yonging.
And you won't know that if the UK is
going to follow you. Okay. All right.
Try it.
>> You're just standing. Every step they
have to move you. Not you. You don't
move yourself. Every step they have to
move you. every step.
So what I mean by every step is don't
start falling because that's that lazy
uk.
Every step they have to move you.
Not just the first one. Every step.
Every step.
every step. Yes. That is going to make
Chris way better.
Don't Don't start falling like a
Federite. We don't have any energy here.
Every step you are being moved. Not
falling because they got momentum on
you.
Every step. Now again. Now again. Yes.
Now again.
Good.
Every step you bended him too much.
You got to move his center, not his
head. So this is how we learn Idiag.
>> Good.
Follow the 90 rule
90 degrees to that resistance forward on
the rotational spiral.
So what's happening is the self is
coming up and then you push on it. Okay.
So look here. Here we are. Okay. So I
have your vertical inertia the
resistance. Got that? So I'm going to go
90 to it. That's all I got. Do you see
that? That's it. You keep trying to do
it. That's where I got it. And now I'm
over yongiing because of that foot. Do
you see that?
>> So it's on that foot. So I turn and I go
this way.
There's the foot again.
Uh turn again. 90.
Okay. There's that foot again. Wait,
I'll get there.
There it is. Right there again. And I
turn 90 again.
Do you guys see that? Do you feel that?
Okay. What you're doing instead
>> is you go, there's that foot.
You push there.
>> There's that foot and I move. There's
that foot and I keep moving.
Okay, try it.
Don't try to overpower it. Move. Get a
new 90. Move. Get a new 90. Move a new
90. Move a new 90. Move a new 90.
Yep. Be patient. There's no there's no
form you're trying to follow. It's just
an energy relationship you're trying to
follow.
[Music]
Stay on the front. Don't let his head
turn. Don't let his head turn back
towards you. You don't give back energy.
You're let you're pushing him away.
You're letting his head turn into you.
So, you're here. We'll do it on the same
side. Okay. You're here like that and
you're traing them this way.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So, there's that foot, Chris. Do
you feel that foot? Okay. So, I got to
move to get a new angle
just off of it. There it is right there.
Okay. Then the heel is there. Do you see
>> the heel is there? You feel it?
>> And I move again and I do another one.
Okay. And all you need is that. You
don't need the 360s we're doing. We're
just using that to prolongate
the skill development. 90 degree
fluctuation. Okay. All right. Try it
again.
Feel
the foot turn.
Okay,
Virginia. Let me
Okay, so
when I go there's her there's her heel
right now. That that's her foot right
now. Okay. And now I want you to to
fight that angle. Yep. There it is right
there. And then you feel the adhesion
got stickier. Do you see that? Because
because I'm doing the internals. Okay.
It's not that she overpowers me. It's
that that foot gets driven more into the
ground. Well, I want you to feel this.
Okay. So, I go there. She got she
grounded that foot already. Okay. And
now when you resist, I just internalize.
It's not that she got back to where she
was. It's not that I started trying
harder, but that foot got heavier. Do
you see that? And when that foot gets
heavier, the next 90 angle is going to
have a more pronounced effect. Okay? So,
make it light now. Make it light. Make
reconcile this energy here. Okay? And
I'll do try to try to release that leg a
little more. Lower the yong value even
more. There you go. Cool. Okay. Now the
yong value is lower and you're going to
see how indirect
the first 90 angle is to to this thing
that we get here.
Okay. It kind of takes a while for the
center to go. Okay. So, we'll do now the
other one. You're going to do your
thing. There's her foot. Then I want you
to charge it. Charge it. Cool. And then
I do the same 90. Look, her center goes
first.
Okay. You see that? So, which is why
it works. The high the more aggressive
you are, the more it's going to work
because the yong value goes up. As long
as I'm doing the Iikit tanden, you're
now more captured, not less captured.
Okay? So, if you're coming in to smother
those strikes, boom, you're you're
getting moved. Okay? Does that make
sense? But what was the assumption?
>> I can internalize her yong energy, okay?
And not come back and meet it and try to
push it. Okay? All right. Uh see where
you get with that one. Try that one.
get to the first heel weight or the heel
the leg engaging and then have them
engage it more. Okay? See if you can
ground that and then do the first 90.
See, it's easier to move him now. It's
much easier. Very good, Chris.
You got you got to internalize it. So,
you can't be moving before you move her.
>> Yes, that's it. And now it's like
cheating. Just like the timing the
timing trick is I don't I don't have a
timing problem. That's how I have
perfect timing. It's the same thing
here. If I internalize your resistance,
then I and I I'm going to have I tanden.
This does not take any strength at all.
You're going to be moved. Okay,
switch roles, Chris. You got it. Switch
rolls. Good.
Take him to that foot where you feel it.
And then he's going to up the yang
energy there. And you internalize that,
Andrew. And then take the 90 degrees to
that.
You got you got glute tension.
You got to ground your energy, too.
[Music]
Ground ground. Don't Don't smell the
head tilt. I don't even want his head to
really tilt in this technique. Okay,
>> there. It's going to be over by the time
he starts leaning forward.
>> Ground that. So, ground you first,
Virginia. You got to release everything.
You got to unself.
You You have to stay grounded.
Yep. Yep. Just wait. Be patient. Take
another 90. There you go. Good.
Okay. Go get your Gtop on, please. If
you if you don't have it on, you don't
need anything else. Just your g.
All right. So, uh we're going to grab
the sleeve. Okay.
uh at the elbow and just kind of go with
it at first. Okay. Okay. So, you come
in.
Okay. She's going around.
Gets the sleeve. Okay. Got it. Okay.
Now, the question is, did UK have to go
around?
Got got that. Or am I making them go
around? Okay. And the other way of
asking that same question is could uk
just run straight out cuz if uk could
then I wasn't making them run around me.
I was simply doing my culture of
following. Okay. Got it? Okay. So you
guys are going to come in. That hand's
not going to be there. And let's just
see you run out of the technique. Okay,
go for it. And try to smother that elbow
strike. Go back. You got to smother the
elbow strike. Okay, so you got to come
in with balls. Go.
Go, Sean.
>> You can let him grab it. It's not It's
not going to be that You don't have to
fight that hard. Just keep walking. Yep.
Just Yep. Just keep walking. You're
you're in that selfing state again.
Okay, I'll go. Okay, so this is what I
mean. You can grab anyone. Don't worry
if you rip my shirt. Okay,
you you can grab the shirt. It doesn't
matter. Okay,
it does not take much because there's no
center connection there. You just Okay,
I just gave you one thing. You could
have spun on the inside and do a single
leg, a double leg, right? You could have
done anything. Okay? And all all I'm
showing is that the only way you've
walked around is because you followed.
You just he she can't stop me. Okay? Go
>> calm down. But I want it faster.
>> Yes.
[Music]
Try to bring him around. Nag,
you got to calm down. Bouching. These
these low drills are early drills where
you can get
generate fear and then release. Okay?
There's no one is throwing you and you
are actually the aggressor.
You're you're you're countering early.
>> Okay. You're going like this.
Hi.
>> Just I I go.
>> Do I look freaked out? Okay.
>> Okay. Calm down.
>> Calm down means release the self.
Now start picking up energy while
remaining calm.
[Music]
Okay. So again, there's it's only reason
you went around because you did the
follow thing. The only reason you did
the follow thing because somehow you got
incapacitated with NMI and Naga gets to
do these things which are delusional
which therefore makes my marshall aspect
of my technology of self
anipation
of the unselfing process. Do do you
understand? Okay. So this is all a no.
No. Very very wrong.